LEISURE TRAVEL.
WE'LL EXAMINE THE PANDEMIC.
>>> BUT HERE'S MY TAKE.
THERE IS A STRIKING THING THAT
DISTINGUISHES THIS PANDEMIC FROM
ALL OTHERS IN HISTORY, THE SPEED
WITH WHICH HUMANKIND CAME UP
WITH A VACCINE.
IT IS UNPRECEDENTED AND STILL
BREATHTAKING THAT WITHIN MONTHS
OF THE ARRIVAL OF A NOVEL VIRUS,
SCIENTISTS WERE ABLE TO DEVELOP
AND TEST SEVERAL VACCINES THAT
ALL PROVED TO BE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE AT PREVENTING SERIOUS
ILLNESS.
BUT WHAT SCIENCE HAS GIVEN,
POLITICS SEEMS TO BE TAKING
AWAY.
DESPITE HAVING AMPLE SUPPLIES OF
THE VACCINE, AMERICA IS STUCK
WITH ROUGHLY 60% OF THE ADULT
POPULATION FULLY VACCINATED,
ENSURING THAT THE PANDEMIC WILL
LINGER PERHAPS FOREVER.
GIVEN THE TOOLS TO END THIS
TRAGEDY, WE ARE CHOOSING TO LIVE
WITH IT.
AS THE ECONOMIST POINTS OUT, THE
ANTI-VAX MOVEMENT IN AMERICA
TODAY IS UNPRECEDENTED.
THERE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN PEOPLE
WHO OBJECTED TO VACCINATIONS,
BUT THEY WERE ON THE FRINGE, A
SMATTERING A NAYSAYERS.
THEY WERE USUALLY SMALL, A FEW
OUTBREAKS OF MEASLES NOW AND
THEN.
THIS TIME IT'S DIFFERENT.
IN THE MIDST OF A RAGING
PANDEMIC THAT HAS KILLED 600,000
AMERICANS, WE HAVE SEEN THE RISE
OF A VAST RIGHT-WING CONSPIRACY
THEORY ABOUT THE VACCINES.
IT HAS BEEN STOKED BY
INFLUENTIAL FIGURES IN THE
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA AND
TOLERATED, EVEN ENCOURAGED, BY
POWERFUL REPUBLICAN POLITICIANS.
THE RESULTS ARE DAMNING.
AS OF JUNE, 86% OF DEMOCRATS
HAVE RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOSE
COMPARED WITH JUST 52% OF
REPUBLICANS.
ALL THE STATES WITH THE LOWEST
LEVELS OF VACCINATION,
MISSISSIPPI, ALABAMA, ARKANSAS,
WYOMING AND LOUISIANA VOTED
HEAVILY FOR DONALD TRUMP.
BARELY HALF OF REPUBLICAN HOUSE
MEMBERS REPORT BEING VACCINATED.
NOW, ANTI-VAX SENTIMENT IS NOT
JUST AN AMERICAN PROBLEM.
IN MANY PLACES AROUND THE WORLD,
THERE ARE SEGMENTS OF THE
POPULATION, OFTEN RURAL, OFTEN
LESS EDUCATED, WHO ARE
VACCINE-HESITANT.
BUT THERE ARE FEWER EQUIVALENCE
ANYWHERE AROUND THE WORLD AS THE
UNITED STATES, IN WHICH
MISINFORMATION HAS BEEN SPREAD
ON A WIDE SCALE ABOUT A DEADLY
DISEASE.
IN FACT, AMERICAN MISINFORMATION
HAS NOW GONE GLOBAL,
LEGITIMIZING AND ENCOURAGING
ANTI-VAXERS AROUND THE WORLD.
LIKE THE U.S., FRANCE HAS HAD
HIGH LEVEL OF ANTI-VAXER
SENTIMENT, BUT POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP SEEMS TO BE CHANGING
THINGS THERE.
THEIR PRESIDENT RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED THAT EMPLOYEES WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO BE VACCINATED,
AND THE UNVACCINATED WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO ENTER CINEMAS,
RESTAURANTS OR TAKE TRAINS OR
PLANES.
THIS HAS DRAWN NEGATIVE
SENTIMENT, BUT MILLIONS HAVE
SIGNED UP FOR THE VACCINE SINCE
MACRON IMPOSED THESE RULES.
THOUGH HEAVY HANDED, THEY ARE
NOT SPREADING MISINFORMATION
ABOUT VACCINES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN NEEDS TO GET
TOUGH.
HE SHOULD EXPLAIN THAT WHILE WE
CHERISH FREEDOM IN AMERICA, YOU
DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING WHEN IT
ENDANGERS THE LIVES OF OTHERS OR
PLACES BURDENS ON THEM.
HERE ARE SOME THINGS YOU ARE
FORCED TO DO EVEN IN AMERICA.
GO TO SCHOOL.
PAY TAXES.
REGISTER FOR THE DRAFT IF YOU
ARE MALE.
SERVE ON A JURY.
THERE ARE ALSO MANY THINGS THAT
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DO THAT
MIGHT BE MISTAKENLY SEEN AS
INVOLVING NO ONE ELSE.
YOU MAY NOT BUY OR SELL
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES, LITTER ON
PUBLIC STREETS, MAKE LOUD NOISE
AFTER CERTAIN HOURS, AND SO ON.
IF YOU DRIVE A CAR, YOU ARE
REQUIRED TO GET A LICENSE, BUY
INSURANCE, WEAR A SEAT BELT,
OBEY STREET SIGNS AND SPEED
LIMITS, HAVE THE CAR INSPECTED
AND NOT DRINK ALCOHOL BEFORE
DRIVING.
IF YOU WANT YOUR CHILDREN TO GO
TO A PUBLIC SCHOOL IN AMERICA,
THEY MUST BE VACCINATED.
THESE ARE ALL MANDATES BECAUSE
SEEMINGLY PRIVATE ACTIONS
ACTUALLY IMPOSE PUBLIC COSTS.
YOU SHOULD NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
SPREAD DISEASE AND OCCUPY A
PRECIOUS HOSPITAL BED.
SOME REPUBLICAN POLITICIANS AND
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA FIGURES ARE
FINALLY URGING PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED, BUT THEY MAY BE TOO
LATE.
AS THEY DID WITH THE RISE OF
DONALD TRUMP, THE ALLEGATIONS OF
VOTER FRAUD AND THE ACCUSATIONS
OF A STOLEN ELECTION, THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS INDULGED
ITS CRAZIES FOR TOO LONG,
FANNING THE FLAMES OF FALSEHOOD
AND CREATING A MIASMA OF
MISINFORMATION.
EVEN NOW, LEADING REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS LIKE RON DeSANTIS ARE
MAKING IT PRUDENT TO REQUIRE
VACCINATION IN FLORIDA.
REPUBLICANS SAY THEY ARE FOR
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND AGAINST
LOCKDOWNS, BUT IT IS THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND THE
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA, BY THEIR
ACTIONS AND NEGLIGENCE, THAT A